kyle cody's season numbers seven games
four starts nice era 153 few too many
walks but that total got a lot better in
his last start pitch five innings didn't
walk a batter and he's been tough to hit
lead man aboard the form of springer now
here's altuve
goes after the second pitch as well this
one out to left field where solac
corrals it for the first out of the ball
game springer now at second base but
with two away one two
and this one on the ground to short stop
high hop for kind of falafel throws out
bregman and the inning is done bottom of
the first jose orkidi has taken the
mound for the astros on the potential
clinch day that right arm has produced a
one-on-one record at 2.78 era that whip
is beautiful right at that 1.01 mark
connor falefa leaped off
connor falefa swings and it's a
one-hopper right to l2v at second base
izzy is out and here's willie calhoun a
one breaking ball grounded right side
into the shift altuve to his right and
short right field off balance throw to
first in time thrown across his body to
get calhoun
that ball into left field and a one two
three inning for jose or kitty two
ground outs and a fly
here's sam huff hitting 292 with a homer
and a run batted in in 24 at bats
and he hits that ball well deep out to
left field tucker looking up gone
a home run
sam huff's second long ball
and then you get a glimpse
of that big-time power we've heard about
from his days in the minor leagues you
could tell you could tell the powers
there not by how far that ball went
because it just barely cleared the wall
but he just kind of flicked the bat at
that pitch it's a hanging breaking ball
he just kind of reaches out and nice
smooth swing
didn't even come close to getting all of
that ball rangers with a one-nothing
lead over the astros top of the fifth
inning carlos correa stands in against
kyle cody carlos correa leading things
off with a 2-2 count correa backhanded
by dietrich long throw correa safe how
about that stretch at first base by
guzman here's springer just two hits for
the astros so far
that ball's hit hard towards left field
down for a hit on the move is correa
he's gonna get to third he's gonna be
waved around here comes the throw from
short in safely is carlos correa with a
head first slide springer ends up on
third the astros have tied the game at
one correa flying around the bases ties
the game up that's what's beautiful
about being a base runner with two outs
you can go on the swing so as soon as
you see george swinging you can
anticipate contact and get a good jump
and then you add that good jump to the
good speed that carlos correa has so
huff with a chance to untie it in this
fifth inning well off just 22 years old
he's talked about the learning curve
this year looks this one deep out to
right field it's gone
huff goes the other way for a home run
his second of the night and indeed he
unties the game it's two to one wow i'd
say he's getting a little bit
comfortable at the major league level
and that's pretty impressive you got a
youngster just getting his feet wet at
the big league level accounting for both
runs this one on a fastball that he goes
the other way with john king checks in
the game now one out going on for
bregman who's over two
and bregman hits it well and deep to
left field it sends back solac at the
wall looking up see you later
[Applause]
alex bregman homers for a second
straight day
and the astros tie it at two
when he can get the ball in the air to
the left side these days bregman feels
good about his chances to ride it out of
here and here's huff huff with home runs
in both of his at bats today the pitch
line to right it's a base hit for huff
cut off deep in the alley by reddick
gallow around to third base it's a long
single for huff he is three for three
two of the hits for the opposite field
and it'll bring up dietrich with first
and third and two outs in the game tied
in the sixth swing and a miss got him
with a change up away so he avoids any
damage in the inning base hit two left
on it is still two to two as eli white
stands in white one for two
there's a liner to left field it's gonna
carry and it's caught by tucker kyle
tucker sliding and making the catch
for the second night in a row of a great
catch by kyle
[Applause]
hit sharply altuve is there though in
the ship and he makes the play to retire
calhoun and the inning nice job by jose
or kitty tonight seven innings of two
run baseball certainly seeing euler come
up big before in key situations pitch on
the way and julie grounds this one off
the glove of a diving guzman and
trickles in the right for a base hit
altuve around third he'll score brantley
goes to third it's an rbi for guriel and
the astros lead at three to two
yuli picked the right time for a base
hit in this game it's now a three to two
astros lead so ryan presley will try and
close things out and send the astros to
the
foul caught by maldonado
what a play by martine it popped out of
his glove and then he made a diving
catch for the out i have never seen that
martine maldonado with an acrobatic
catch of a strikeout now ronald guzman
bats two out bottom half of the ninth
inning ball hit down the right field
line hit well and this ball is gone
astros were one strike away from
qualifying for the postseason and ronald
guzman spoils and delays the celebration
with a home run as he hits one to tie
the game at three
and the infield is in with altuve the go
ahead run at third for bregman
alex sends one into right field that's
deep enough to score the run catching it
is gallow altuve can trot home the
astros regain the lead four to three
here in the 10th inning so now the
rangers are in pretty good shape they've
got the bases loaded nobody out here's
sola swinging a high fly ball deep into
right center field springer going back
to his left onto the track and in front
of the wall he makes the catch white
tags and scores from third easily we're
tied at four the other runners also move
up lefty in now to face joey gallo with
a game on the line the 2-1 pitch
swinging a bouncing ball right side
altuve has it he throws home wide of the
plate tyner falefe scores and the
rangers walk it off and the rangers win
it in walk-off fashion here off the bat
of joey gallo